une série de comportements violents tels
que depuis plus d'un an
leylaz rémy se bat devant le tribunal
des droits de la personne
son fils a été selon elle victimes de
discrimination raciale à son ancienne
école près toronto il était plaquée sur
le sol mais à plusieurs incidents avec
trois haltes au maximum engagé sur lui
l'enfant avait 6 ans à l'époque
selon le conseil scolaire il aurait
blessé des membres du personnel et les
oreilles menacé avec des ciseaux
pourtant cette année là l'école n'a
rapporté aucun incident violent au
ministère de ne pas l'admettre ou le
reporter au ministère c'est une
injustice à l'enfant en ontario c'est
pourtant obligatoire depuis 2011
les ministères compile des données sur
les agressions graves et sexuelle les
actes haineux et les menace avec une
arme
siby si radio canada a obtenu ces années
en vertu de la loi sur l'accès à
l'information et trouver une douzaine de
cas jamais rapporté quatre cas sont
survenus dans des écoles francophones
incluant deux cas d'abus sexuels envers
des enfants
la suite de notre enquête plusieurs
conseils scolaires nous ont dit qu'ils
allaient réviser leurs données ça
voudrait dire que les données de la
province ne sont pas fiables lance cet
expert
dans ce cas dit il un possible d'allouer
les ressources au bon endroit ils
trouvaient des solutions ça ne me
surprend pas c'est un sujet très
important tous les membres de la foux
également pour pour les fous même je
dois vous dire que ça fait partie des
discussions la table de négociations le
ministre a réagi jeudi en disant qu'il
avait demandé à son ministère d'examiner
le problème le ministère et pourtant au
courant de ces irrégularités depuis
plusieurs années selon un mémo datant de
2016 que nous avons obtenu les la rémy
elle n'a plus confiance
je me demande est ce que le ministère
est là juste pour amasser la donner et
ne rien faire avec la
résultat